[Music]
hello and welcome to the Business
Analytics with Excel course offered by
simply learned this video will give you
an overview about the importance of
analytics in business today why it is in
demand among a lot of organizations and
how you can effectively leverage
Microsoft Excel for data analytics it is
quite clear that businesses must
understand the changing market and
trends in social media to stay ahead of
the competition and drive effective
business decisions what can help
businesses maintain their competitive
edge the answer lies in business
analytics the term business analytics
refers to the skills technologies
applications and practices that
facilitate continuous iterative
exploration and investigation of past
business performance customer data and a
competitive landscape data the goal is
to gain insights and drive business
planning therefore business analytics
empowers businesses to automate and
optimize business processes thereby
enabling them to sustain the competitive
advantage
Microsoft Excel has extensive analytics
capabilities to perform statistical
analysis with the added advantage of
visibility a flat learning curve and
good reporting functionalities Excel has
become the tool of choice to start your
data analytics journey did you know
Excel offers intuitive analytics
features such as find connect and shape
to model and analyze a company's data
today Excel comes with in-memory
technology that makes it easily
compatible with millions of bytes of
data enabling companies to perform the
necessary analysis without being
dependent on specialized solutions
additionally features such as power
business intelligence including power
pivot power query power view power Maps
and so on easily integrate with Excel
the sandbox like Excel environment makes
data exploration and deriving results
quite easy it includes features to
perform powerful data analytics
processes with just one click instead of
using a complex set of formulas pivot
tables and manual steps with
increasingly diverse tool sets being
added to excel it's very clear that
Excel is the business intelligence tool
of choice and the future of business
intelligence workflows and is being
increasingly preferred by analysts
reporting professionals and bi people
Excel provides a grid-like interface of
rows and columns
enabling users to organize and format
data better the data can be simple text
numbers dates or other supported formats
excels libraries span a large range of
functions from basic math to complex
statistical formula it cannot be said
enough that Excel is pivotal to
organizations as it is the leading
user-friendly analytical tool
Amazon in American electronic commerce
and cloud computing company has been in
business for more than twenty years it
has a user base of millions of customers
ever wondered how Amazon predicts
exactly what customers want to buy it's
simple or let's just say it's simple
business analytics that involves
understanding the patterns of what
happened in the past to predict what
might happen in the future
currently this is a requirement of every
business
simply learns business analytics with
Excel course introduces you to excel the
powerful data analysis tool that will
enable you to collect data and perform
an in-depth analysis of the data to
drive effective impactful business
decisions designed it to build upon the
concepts and procedures in data
analytics the primary focus of the
course is to learn how to use Excel to
perform a multivariate statistics and to
understand how to explore experiment and
forecast results with Excel histograms
pivot tables statistics and mathematical
formulas and charts after attending this
course you should be able to understand
business problems and data sets perform
calculations using statistical
techniques conduct a variety of
statistical analyses including
regressions covariance correlation and
testing hypotheses present and interpret
the results of statistical now
design dynamic reports and dashboards
for business consumption this highly
engaging course features concept videos
with exercises which will empower you
with hands-on experience the course
covers introduction to business
analytics with an overview to different
types of analytics statistical and
mathematical functions after each lesson
practice and revision assessments are
provided to reinforce the concepts
learned the course ends with detailed
case studies outlining real-life
scenarios
simply learn will offer complete support
anytime during the course or while
you're working on the projects if you
subscribe to the live virtual classroom
training you can attend an ongoing batch
and revisit important concepts to seek
help for the projects visit the simply
learn website
wwm play learn calm and click help &
support at the bottom of the page to
submit queries you can also speak
directly to the support staff with the
simply talk or live chat option so are
you ready to begin happy learning
hello and welcome to the lesson
formatting conditional formatting and
important functions in this lesson we
will learn about custom formatting how
to use conditional formatting and
formulas and implement logical
statistical and mathematical functions
let's say we need to differentiate the
sales value from the given data set as
above target below target and met target
as a data set can be huge in complex
differentiating each value manually
would consume a lot of effort and time
here comes the Excel features such as
formatting and conditional formatting
which enables us to perform this task
easily
formatting as the name suggests helps us
to format the data using different
techniques making the data easy to read
in the required format and analyze them
the right formatting technique applied
to the worksheets can help the users
present the data efficiently
conditional formatting a type of
formatting helps us visually explore and
analyze data detect critical issues and
identify patterns and trends
conditional formatting helps to add
patterns and trends to the raw
information using different colors icons
and formulae etc at
times we also need to perform
mathematical operations and calculations
within our data set Excel provides a
large number of logical statistical and
mathematical
functions such as vlookup H lookup and
if not ranked quartile and many more
that can help the users to perform
calculations ranging from basic to
complex operations these inbuilt
functions help us to manage data and
perform descriptive statistical analysis
Excel also offers a wide range of
important formulas that help to perform
many common tasks these formula may be
as simple as basic addition or it could
be a complex combination of in Bill
excel functions before going into
details let us start this lesson by
defining the objectives of the lesson
the worksheets appear more polished and
easy to read if proper formatting
techniques are applied to it we can
format the cells in Microsoft Excel
manually by selecting fonts font color
font size background colors and borders
we can also use numerous predefined
table styles or quick styles to quickly
format a table automatically this is the
basic formatting in Excel if these
built-in functions do not meet our needs
or do not display the data in the format
that we require we can create our own
custom format in this topic will focus
on custom formatting in Excel let's say
we want to display one million five
hundred and thirty two thousand as 1.53
m or the first of January 2016 date with
a weekday as the first Friday January
2016 here we can use custom formatting
feature of Excel let's see how we can
accomplish this in Excel
in this lesson we shall consider the
following fields from our master table
dates order ID product salesman region
number of customers net sales and profit
and loss here in the given worksheet we
have a column named net sales suppose we
want to display the values of net sales
in terms of thousands for example seven
thousand one hundred and sixty-four
should be displayed a seven point one
six K
select the entire column for net sales
under the Home tab click the drop-down
present in the numbers panel select the
option more number formats a format
cells dialog box appears from the
category list select the type as custom
in the type text box enter number column
number number 0 decimal 0 0 comma open
double quote capital K close double
quote
here number is the digit holder with
thousand comma separation each comma
after decimal zero zero indicating
the two zeros after decimal point
indicate number of value after decimal
places the K component displays a
literal K character to denote thousands
here we can see the preview in sample
box the value shown is seven point one
six K finally click OK button
the values in column net sales are now
displayed in terms of thousands
now let us consider another example of
date formatting
in the column dates we have a date value
written as first Jan 2012 we want to
display it as first Sunday Jan 2012
first select the column containing dates
tab click the drop-down present in
numbers panel select the option more
number formats a format cell dialog box
appears from the category list select
the type as custom
in the type text box enter DD - DD DD -
mmm - why why
here d stands for date M stands for
month and y stands for year the first 2
D D is the date the next 4 D D D D is
for weekday say Thursday
then mmm is for the month in short form
and YY is for year here we can see in
the preview in the sample box the values
shown is one Sunday Jan 12 finally click
on OK button
you
thus the custom formatting helps us in
changing the appearance of the cell
value according to our needs a worksheet
may contain thousands of rows of data by
simply examining the raw information it
would be difficult to see patterns and
trends conditional formatting helps us
visualize data that make worksheets
easier to understand it quickly
highlights important information in a
spreadsheet by using colors icons and
data bars it changes the appearance of
one or more cells when the cell value
meets certain criteria to do this we
need to create a conditional formatting
rule for example a conditional
formatting rule can be if value is
greater than 5,000 color the cell yellow
by applying this rule we were able to
quickly see which cells contain values
that are greater than 5,000 let us
understand this with the help of
examples
consider the given sales table which
depicts the amount of sales done by each
salesman here we want to highlight the
duplicate order ID values first select
the order ID column
click Home tab under
styles panel select the option
conditional formatting
from the drop down menu hover the mouse
over highlight cells rules and select
duplicate values a duplicate values
dialog box appears
select a formatting style from the
drop-down menu in our example we will
choose green fill with dark green text
click OK here
we can see that the conditional
formatting is applied to the column
order ID Excel highlights all the
duplicate cells with green fill with
dark green text
we can also explore other options
available in conditional formatting like
greater than less than between equal to
text that contains a date occurring and
top / bottom rules all these rules work
in the similar format
Excel provides predefined styles to
quickly apply conditional formatting to
our data they are data bars data bars
are horizontal bars added to each column
much like a bar graph
color scales color scales change the
color of each cell based on its value
each color scale uses a two or three
color gradient icon sets icon sets add
specific icon to each cell based on its
value
let us consider another example to
explain how icon set rules are used
consider the given sales table here on
the basis of the sales amount we want to
apply the icon set rule if sales amount
is greater than 8000 then a green arrow
should appear in the upward direction if
sales amount is between 5,000 and 8,000
then show a yellow arrow in the
horizontal direction and if sales amount
is less than 5,000 then show a red arrow
in the downward direction
to perform conditional formatting select
the desired cells
click on Home tab under
styles panel select the option
conditional formatting
from the drop down menu hover the mouse
over icon set rules and select the first
rule
again click on conditional formatting
select the option manage rules from the
drop-down a conditional formatting rules
manager dialog box appears
- icon set rule and select three icon
set rule
click on edit rule and an edit rule
formatting dialog box appears
by default for three icon set rule Excel
uses the 67th percentile and the 33%
I'll rule this means that it shows a
green arrow for values greater than 67%
yellow arrows for values between 67 and
33% and red arrow for values less than
33%
now let us customize this rule for our
criteria in the type drop-down select
the option as number
you
in the value reference box enter value
is 8,000 for green color arrow and 5,000
for yellow color arrow
Excel automatically picks the criteria
for the red color arrow click OK in the
conditional formatting rules manager
window click OK
we can see that the cells are
highlighted as per our criteria cells
which have a value greater than 8000
have a green arrow in the upward
direction
values between 5k and 8k are highlighted
with a yellow arrow and values less than
5k are highlighted with a red arrow
we can also apply conditional formatting
rule with the help of formulas consider
the given table which shows the profit
done by each salesman here we want to
highlight the rows in the table where
ever profit is greater than 4000
select the entire table along with
headings
click on conditional formatting select
the option new rule from the drop-down a
new formatting rule dialog box appears
under select rule type select the option
use a formula to determine which cells
to format under format values reference
box and to the formula as equals if Open
bracket dollar sign h2 greater than 4000
comma true comma bolts close bracket
this will apply formatting to a cell if
the profit is greater than 4000 click on
format button from the format cells
dialog box select the fill tab from the
color dialog box select the color as
green finally click OK
the conditional formatting is
successfully applied to the cells here
we can see that the cells with the
profit greater than 4000 are highlighted
with the green color
logical functions evaluate a cell or
cells for our criteria and returns a
boolean value true or false in this
topic we will cover various logical
functions like if and/or not true false
consider the given sales table here on
the basis of the sales amount we want to
determine the commission percentage of
each salesman following is the criteria
if net sales greater than or equal to
10,000 set commission as 5% if net sales
greater than or equal to 5,000 and less
than or equal to 10,000 set Commission
as 2.5% if net sales less than 5,000 set
Commission as 1.5%
this is a common condition where we're
required to create a between formula
that picks all values between the two
given values in such conditions we use
if with the and function let's write the
formula in cell I five like any other
formula we will start with the equal
sign then type our function e if and
then type in open parentheses the first
parameter we need to pass is a logical
test here the logical test is if sales
cell G 5 greater than or equal to 10,000
a sign value as 5% then we will pass the
second logical test here we will use an
function if open bracket and open
bracket sale that cell G 5 greater than
or equal to 5,000 comic at cell G 5 less
than or equal to 10,000 a comma a signed
value as 2.5% in the else parameter we
will type 1.5 percent this means that if
the first two cases become false then
the formula will assign the value 1.5
finally close the two braces for the two
ifs thus Excel returns the result as
2.5% for cell G 5 now drag the formula
with the help of the fill handle we can
see the results for the other cells as
well
the or function returns true if any of
the conditions are true and returns
false if all of the conditions are false
a given table we are required to assign
performance remarks for each salesman as
per the scaling table
in scaling table we have the criteria
that if net sales greater than 10,000 or
profit greater than 5,000 set remark as
good else set remark as needs
improvement
let's write the formula using if and or'
to check sales and maximum sales in cell
j5
so our formula becomes equals if open
bracket or open bracket g5 greater than
10,000 comma H 5 greater than or equal
to 5,000 comma double quote good double
quote comma double quote need
improvement double quote close bracket
let's drag this formula across the cells
with the help of the fill handle
this formula returned true if any of the
condition is true thus in the given
example the cell j9 returns good even if
profit is less than five thousand
our next function is true / false true /
false returns true and false
respectively if we write them in any
cell
the not function reverses the result of
the function if result is true it
returns false else true let's write
formula as equal not open bracket k5
closed bracket in cell l5 this returns
the result as false
let us now study about different lookup
and reference functions used in Excel
such as vlookup each lookup match index
and offset function the vlookup function
lets us search for specific information
in the current worksheet say we have a
list of students with marks we can
search for the marks of a specific
student if our table is in horizontal
format and we want to determine a
specific value then we use the H lookup
function
consider the extract from our master
sales table the table depicts sales
information based on order ID products
sold salesman and net sales now we want
to determine the net sales corresponding
to order ID 1 1 2 1
let's understand how we can accomplish
this using the vlookup function
note that vlookup function is only used
for vertical tables let's use cell I to
to add the formula like any other
formula we will start with the equal
sign then type our function named
vlookup and then type and open
parenthesis
now we will add the arguments the first
argument is lookup value lookup value
corresponds to the value or item we are
searching for so in our example it will
be order ID 1 1 2 1 cell H 2 the second
argument is table array table array is
the cell range that contains the data in
this example our data is in cell b2 to e
40
you
you
the third argument is called index num
column index number the column index
number is the column number in which we
are looking for information here in our
table array net sales is the fourth
column so our third argument will be for
the fourth argument is range lookup this
value corresponds if we are looking for
approximate matches or not and can have
value either true or false true denotes
the approximate match and false denotes
the exact match here we will pass false
finally close the parentheses so our
function has the form equal vlookup open
bracket h2 comma B 2 : e 4 t comma 4
comma false close bracket we can see
that the function returns the value as 2
- 7 7 note that the vlookup function
works from left to right that means the
lookup value should always be present in
the leftmost column of our table array
if our table is in horizontal format and
we want to determine a specific value
then we use the H lookup function
consider the given table let's write the
formula in cell I for we will start with
the equal sign then type our function
name each lookup and then type open
parentheses the first argument is the
lookup value so in our example it will
be order ID equals 1 1 - 1
cell 8 for
the second argument is table array in
this example our data is in cell G 8 2
is 11
the third argument is row index number
here our table array net sales is the
fourth row so our third argument will be
4 the fourth argument is range lookup
here we will pass false finally close
the parentheses so our function has the
form equals H lookup open bracket H 4
comma G 8 : a s 11 comma 4 comma false
close bracket the function returns the
value - 2 7 7 note that H lookup
function works from left to right that
means lookup value should always be in
the topmost row of your table array
the match function searches for a
specified value in an item in a single
dimensional array and then returns the
relative position of that item in the
array let us understand its functioning
with the help of an example consider the
given sales table shown here we want to
determine the position of the
corresponding date in the original table
so let's write the formula in cell e5
type equal sign then type the function
name match and then type an open
parenthesis
the first argument is the lookup value
so in our example it will be date in
cell b5
the second argument is lookup array the
lookup array is a range of cells that
contains the value we are searching for
in this example we will select the cells
b-17 to be 1 3 4 2
you
you
the third argument is match type match
type can be either -1 0 or 1
should be one if we want to find the
largest value less than or equal to the
lookup value
the value should be zero if we want to
find the first value exactly equal to
lookup value
it should be minus one if we want to
find the smallest value greater than or
equal to lookup value here we'll pass a
match type as zero as we require an
exact match finally close the
parentheses so our function should look
like match Open bracket B five comma
dollar sign B dollar sign seventeen :
dollar sign B dollar sign 1 3 4 2 comma
zero close bracket
this returns the value as 3 now we can
drag the formula across cells with the
help of the fill handle
similarly we can use the match formula
in cell III to determine the position of
the shown field name cell c3 in range
b-17 to I 7 teen for example net sales
is at 7th position in the range b-17 to
i 17 let's write the function in cell
III write formula as equal sign match
and open parentheses in the first
argument select cell c3 for second
argument select cells b-17 to I 7 teen
past third argument is 0 finally close
the parentheses so our function looks
like equal match open bracket C 3 comma
dollar sign B dollar sign 17 : dollar
sign I dollar sign 17 comma 0 close
bracket so for profit loss field the
value returned is 8
net sale the value returned is seven
the index function returns value from a
specified position in a specific column
in a list suppose we want to determine
the value of the field mentioned in cell
c3 from the sales table on a specified
date the table should dynamically fetch
the value if the value of the cell c3
has changed and if we enter profit loss
formula should fetch the profit loss
value for the specified date if we write
net sales in cell c3 then formula should
fetch net sales value for specified date
so let's use the index function to
determine the value in this worksheet
select cells c5 write formula as equal
sign index and open parentheses the
first argument is the array for our
example enter b-17 colon i1 342
you
the second argument is the roan um this
corresponds to the row number that has
the value we want to return here we will
enter a five which denotes the required
date
the third column is call num this
corresponds to the column number that
has the value we want to return here we
will enter III which denotes the
position of the field name in cell c3 in
table
finally close the parentheses
thus our formula returns the value as
6500 and 28 based on the position at
cells c5 this is the net sales value on
the date the second of January
now drag the formula with the fill
handle to the other cells as well
the offset function returns a reference
to a range that is the offset number of
the rows and columns from another range
or cell now let's understand how to use
it select cell d5 right formula is equal
sign offset and open parenthesis the
first argument is the reference this
denotes the starting range from which
the offset will be applied for our
example we will select the reference
cell as b-17
the second argument is the rose this
denotes the number of rows to apply as
the offset to the reference this can be
a positive or a negative number so for
our example we will enter a 5 minus 1
here we are subtracting 1 to match
number of row which have the value and
the offset from the reference cell the
third argument is the calls this
corresponds to the column number that
has the value we want to return here we
will enter III which denotes the
position of the field name and subtract
by 1 to match with the offset
referencing finally close the
parentheses the function returns the
value based on the position of date from
cell b5 and field from cell c3 now drag
the formula across the cells with the
help of the fill handle if we enter
profit loss formula should fetch the
profit loss value for the specified date
a variety of statistical functions are
available in Excel to perform
calculations ranging from basic function
mean median and mode to more composite
distribution and test binomial or chai
square in this topic we will cover
various statistical functions like sum
if countifs percentile quartile standard
deviation and median
some ifs and countifs are the most
frequently used functions in Excel these
functions allow us to perform count and
some based on one or more criteria the
sum ifs function calculates the sum of
cells based on certain criteria
let's understand how to use the function
with the help of an example consider the
given sales table say we want to
determine the net sales done by salesman
Justin
here we will use the sum ifs function to
calculate net sales so let's write the
formula in cell n4 type equal sign then
type the function name some ifs and then
type in open parenthesis the first
argument is the sum range this is the
input range that contains the required
data so in our example we will select
cells h4 to H
1328 the second argument is the criteria
range this denotes the range that
contains the required criteria here will
pass the range that holds salesman's
name cells efore to e
1328 the third argument is criteria this
corresponds to our required criteria we
only require net sales of the salesman
Justin so we will select cell m4
finally close the parentheses note that
we can pass multiple criteria in this
function the function returns the net
sales done by Justin
countifs function works in a similar
manner like some ifs it counts the
number of cells in a given range when
certain criteria is met say in the given
sales table we want to determine the
total number of sales for net sales
greater than 8,000 to determine the
count we will use the countifs function
so let's write the formula in cell n 5
type the equal sign then type the
function name
countifs and then type in open
parentheses the first argument is the
criteria range one this denotes the
range that contains the required
criteria here we will pass the cells
containing net sales h4 to H
1328
the second argument is criteria one this
corresponds to our required criteria we
only require entries with net sales
greater than eight thousand so we will
enter greater than eight thousand
finally close the parentheses
note that the function allows you to
enter multiple criteria so n5 reflects
the total number of sales as four
hundred and forty five for net sales
greater than eight thousand in
this topic we will learn how to use the
functions percentile quartile standard
deviation and median in Excel
consider the given sales table let's see
how to use the percentile function on
net sales to find its 40th percentile
select the cell and 6 write the formula
as equal sign percentile open bracket
select the column net sales H for 2h
1328 as our first argument pass the
second argument as
0.4 in order to find the fortieth
percentile this returns the result
5220 this means that 40% of the net
sales is less than or equal to
5220
the next function is quartile quartile
function depicts the results for the
first second third and fourth quartile
say we want to find the total number of
sales which are less than or equal to
25% let's use the quartile function to
calculate this selects ln7 to write the
formula
type equal sign function name is
quartile and open braces select net
sales column H for 2h
1328 as the first argument
type 1 as the second argument
the second argument must be a number
between 0 & 4 the function returns the
value as
3822 which means that 25% of the sale is
less than or equal to three thousand
eight hundred and twenty two note that
here we can use the percentile function
to perform the same task the function
percentile H for 2h
1328 comma 0.25 gives us the same result
it's up to us which function we would
like to use for the quartiles
Excel has a function to calculate sample
standard deviations
stdev
standard deviation determines how
dispersed the data is from the mean say
we want to calculate the standard
deviation for a number of customers
so write the formula in cell n8 as
equals the function name stdev open
braces
select number of customers columns as
its argument
the function returns a result one point
for
the median function returns the value
from the range for example we want to
find the mid value for net sales to
calculate median in sell and nine write
the formula as equal sign the function
named median then open braces select net
sales column as its argument
this calculates the mid value of net
sales as six thousand one hundred ninety
two
rank function is used to compare a
number from the rest of the numbers in
list in any order whether ascending or
descending this function returns the
rank of the number relative to the other
values in the list let's use rank
function in cell j4 to calculate rank on
the basis of net sales select cell j4
and write the formula as equal sign then
type the function name rank and then
type in open parentheses the first
argument is the number this is the value
whose rank we're required to calculate
here we will pass the argument cell h4
the second argument is ref this
corresponds to the array or reference
list here we will select the column net
sales ie cells h4 to H
1328
you
the third number is order this specifies
how to rank the number zero means
descending order and one denotes
ascending order this argument is
optional if we don't pass any argument
Excel automatically takes the argument
zero here we will pass zero finally
close the parentheses here we can see
that Excel has determined the rank for
net sales seven thousand one hundred and
sixty-four as
553
finally we can drag the formula and can
see the rank for the other cells based
on net sales
[Music]
Hey want to become an expert in Big Data
then subscribe to the simply learn
Channel and click here to watch more
such videos to nerd up and get certified
in Big Data click here